- One of the biggest issues
of unhappiness in 2022
in America and beyond,
is the complete and utter
lack of accountability.
(upbeat music)
I'm passionate about accountability.
I think the unbelievable vulnerability
in our ecosystem right now
is people not being
accountable for themselves.
We are now in the
finger-pointing generation.
It's your fault, it's their fault,
it's this institution's fault,
it's this human being's fault.
People think technology's changing us,
I think it's exposing us.
This thing is your gateway
to get out of the thing
that you complain about.
But people would rather
complain about how it is
than put in the work.
When you go into blame
game, you are vulnerable.
People would rather
default into why they can't
than putting in the actions
that allow them to can.
I am remarkably stunned
by the lack of accountability
in our society.
Do you know how liberating it is
when you realize everything's your fault?
It gets real fucking good out here.
(camera shutters click)
Something I'm just thinking a lot about
is I'm asking people
to be more accountable,
but I have to be careful,
because a lot of people's version
of intaking accountability
is beating themselves up.
Just stop judging yourself.
Everybody else is doing
it for you already.
Everybody just wants to point fingers
24 fucking hours a day
and tell you why everybody
else is doing things wrong
in the system, that person, this...
Just fucking firing fingers 24/7
without a thumb and a mirror ever.
Figure out what your fucking thing is
and stop making fucking bullshit excuses.
I just want it so bad for you.
I want it bad for you.
Zero accountability.
It has been completely eliminated.
We must put accountability on a pedestal.
If you're like, "Well, Gary, fuck you,
I grew up in a family
that was very pessimistic
and this is what it is."
Well then what do you want?
Then go to therapy, right?
Do something, fight for it.
Fight to be happy,
listen to positive shit.
That's a funny game.
Miraculous thing happens when you cut out
your most pessimistic friend,
you become more optimistic.
News alert, you're deciding
what life actually is.
It is your subjective call.
(inspiring music)
This is a game of perspective.
I don't understand how
we don't understand that.
There's a very big difference
between, "I'm accountable,"
and, "It's my fault," and, "I
suck, I'm a piece of shit."
It's perspective.
I think about World War II.
I think about so many genocides.
I think about the people
and the millions of people
around the world that don't
have clean water every day.
I'm not capable of dwelling,
because of gratitude.
Accountability, what
am I gonna do about it?
And perspective.
And so, I'm what do I say?
I say we should be thankful
that we can even have this conversation,
health over everything,
and just perspective, man,
it's just perspective.
(inspiring music continues)
My friends, do you know how
rare it is to have a life?
The odds right now, currently,
that science accepts for the
odds of actually being alive
is 400 trillion to 1.
(children voices)
One life, baby.
One life.
- One life.
- One life, one.
- One.
If you are a good person
and you're trying,
truly trying and not
trying to hurt anybody,
you're fucking phenomenal.
(audience applauds)
Enough.
Lack of accountability.
This is the key to the whole thing.
The mindset of accountability
is what makes you win, makes you happy,
whether it's true or not.
Got it?
The thought of taking on responsibility
for everything that's
not working is the win
whether you're right or wrong.
(inspiring music fades)